le seul truc que j'ai jamais pu m'offrir
avec l'argent c'est
comme vous êtes le roi de la tchatche
vous allez finir mes phrases
je vous donne le début vous me donnez la
fin
en ce moment je sais pas ce que j'ai
mais
ça se présente pas mal
c'est bien un truc que je sais pas faire
c'est
faire semblant
la seule différence entre le théâtre et
la politique c'est quand on tue au
théâtre c'est pour faire rire
bravo
ce qui manque un Chirac par rapport à
Mitterrand c'est Jacques Séguéla le seul
truc que j'ai jamais pu m'offrir avec
l'argent c'est
le Crédit Lyonnais
je me serais remboursé plus tôt
[Musique]
en général je plie aux femmes qui ont
quand le goût du risque au moins oui
franchement maintenant je peux te le
dire l'émission que je faisais sur TF1
je regrette de l'avoir arrêté
allez
allez comme tu as une bonne tête maman
te rendors
que tu fais pas la différence entre
l'acier et l'or parce que c'est une
relation
tu avais des barreaux en quoi en or ou
en acier à la santé
avec moi parce qu'un jour j'ai gardé ça
et je l'ai gardé on est on faisait
l'émission sur Canal juste avant que
juste avant que j'y aille j'ai un truc
pour toi tu le regarderas quand tu seras
parti et il me files une carte de ma
poche et quand je sors je regarde ce que
c'est c'était carte du Monopoly vous
êtes libéré de prison
[Applaudissements]
qui s'est remette son micro en direct à
la télévision
ce que tu as tu sens plus heureux
mais il y a même pas de comparaison
que ça y est quoi voilà le jour de mai
60 ans je me suis dit tout marche allez
tout marche ah ouais pas besoin de
viagra de cialisme c'est là-dedans
et franchement si tu avais été au ballon
à ma place je suis sûr que
[Applaudissements]
le combat le plus dur que j'ai eu à
mener c'est
une chanson de Brassens qui dit les gens
n'aiment pas que on suivent pas le même
chemin que ouais c'est un peu ce contre
cela que c'était durer
différents quoi ça ils sont nombreux
aujourd'hui ce qui me rend le plus fier
c'est
mes enfants les quatre c'est marrant
malgré tout ce que j'ai vécu je continue
à croire que
qu'il faut toujours y croire
des fois je me dis si seulement j'avais
pas
alors ça je me le dis jamais
jamais
pas une fois je me suis dit ah si
j'avais su jamais parce que dans la vie
j'ai pas de rétroviseur mais par contre
je garde c'est ce qui fait que je garde
jamais de mauvais souvenirs des gens qui
m'ont fait chier je promets à celui qui
me traite encore dans à 10 mètres
chez moi j'aimerais que ce soit j'ai
fait une des écoles pour les jeunes qui
étaient sans boulot et on en a sorti
près de 10000 sans rien demander à
personne et il y en a près de 10000 ans
la nature qui ont eu une belle carrière
à Sam parmi tous les salopards qui m'ont
trahi je n'oublierai jamais
que mes potes n'étaient pas dans le Lot
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
inarriture abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu